the world has enough oil but not enough
refineries to process it that's the
assessment from the biggest crude
exporter saudi arabia so is this to
blame for record higher fuel prices and
what are the solutions this is inside
story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nastasia tay now global oil prices
have hit record highs for months the
rise has been blamed on the war in
ukraine and surging demand as economies
recover from this pandemic another
reason though is a lack of refineries to
turn crude oil what's dug up from the
ground into useful products such as
petrol diesel and jet fuel well the
price of brent crude the international
benchmark started this year at just
below 80 a barrel it went above 100 on
february the 28th as you can see that
four days after russia invaded ukraine
and then reached 128
a week later on march the 8th the price
has stayed above 100 a barrel since then
with the exception of just a few days
now for many of us this leads to high
prices at petrol pumps oil-producing
countries have promised to increase
production to meet demand but the
world's biggest oil exporter saudi
arabia says the focus should rather be
on boosting refining capacity
today we don't see a lack of oil in the
market there is a lack of refining
capacity which is also an issue so we
need to invest more in a refining
capacity and that that's a policy
decision that countries especially
consuming countries need to make
to ensure that there is enough capacity
to refu to refine the oil that is
available
well speaking of capacity the
international energy agency says the
world has the capacity to refine about a
hundred million barrels of oil a day but
twenty percent is not usable that's due
to a lack of investment in refineries in
some countries particularly in latin
america global output has fallen by 3.3
million barrels a day since 2020 when
the pandemic then slashed demand for
fuel
the u.s has the world's largest refining
capacity but activity there has slowed
to 17.9 million barrels a day that's the
lowest since 2014.
output is also down in other major
refining countries such as china russia
and india
well let's now bring in our guests in
houston we have bob cavanagh he's an
energy and oil analyst and an industry
veteran in berlin we have thomas
o'donnell he is an energy and
geopolitical analyst and also a
consultant on global energy systems and
also in houston is josh young he's the
chief investment officer of bison
interests that's an investment firm
focused on publicly traded oil and gas
companies a warm welcome to you all
gentlemen thank you for joining us today
on inside story there's obviously a big
difference between crude oil which we've
been just looking at the price of and
what you're actually paying at the pump
in terms of prices what is actually to
blame for the high prices that we're
seeing
thomas is it about refining or supply or
both it seems to me potentially both
yeah well i yeah i think you've hit the
nail on the head
and it also you know depends week to
week month to month
the united states is running at a very
high capacity with the refineries as
your story pointed out the refining
capacity is down but the utilization is
basically maxed out 94 97 percent
recently
um but china on the other hand recently
has been running the refineries of you
know something like a third below max
capacity
so there is a shortage of refineries in
the world for what we have to do and
when some are offline like now
in china or for example look venezuela
has a couple of the world's largest
refineries but they've been offline for
a long time what about iran similarly so
that is a problem
but supply of crude is sort of uh the
baseline problem here that's going to
continue into the future uh and that's
wrong to ignore that if the united
states wasn't releasing a million
barrels a day now from the strategic
reserve we'd certainly have problems
well thomas you mentioned the strategic
petroleum reserves there the us and
their allies have released these to try
to cap the huge rise we've seen in fuel
prices
josh let me ask do you think that's made
much of a difference especially because
we're mostly talking about crude here
yeah so uh the the spr release has made
a big difference in the sense that the
market's very tight and um you know i i
agree that that there is this sort of
combination in the short term of a
refining uh crunch as well as oil supply
crunch uh
and and so what we've seen with china um
having reduced their uh refined product
exports as well as russia having
temporarily reduced uh substantially
their exports and now uh they're
starting to export more um what we what
we saw was a
we saw a tight a tight market for
refining but oil would have been i mean
with where demand is right now even with
the refining crunch oil prices might
have been much much higher if the spr
wasn't being released right now
well at this point i want to take a look
at a graph because u.s president joe
biden has accused refineries of raking
in huge profits during a time of war as
we've referred to now the price
difference between a barrel of crude and
the petroleum products refined from it
is called a crack spread so looking at
this graph that's the refining margin
really now usually it's just over what
ten dollars a barrel but it's jumped to
over 55 dollars a barrel and i was
looking at some numbers from bp their
refining market margin is up from 7.7 a
barrel to 35.7
over the past year
let me ask you then bob what do you
think has driven that huge margin
increase is this just down to refining
capacity
it's
like our other guests have said it's
really uh just a complete global market
upset
that is is going on right now where
you've got increasing demand after the
pandemic the u.s and other oil
industries
recovering
after the fall during the pandemic and
then
all of the transportation issues in the
u.s we have huge transportation issues
one of the reasons is the refineries on
the gulf coast a lot of those
can only process only refined heavy
crudes and since we're not importing
heavy crude from like venezuela or or
bunker fuel or gasoline from russia it
causes all kinds of upsets and keeps the
that crack spread very very wide that
will eventually come down
and the thing the thing that most people
don't really realize about the oil and
gas industry is that it is very
competitive
and so if someone is is price gouging so
to speak somebody's going to step into
that space at a lower price if they can
so it's a it's a market upset it will
eventually stabilize but right now
there's so much going on with refinery
capacity with uh with supply upset and
the boycotts
that was mentioned earlier out of iran
and venezuela all causing these problems
at the same time well given the market
upset we're seeing now why not make the
most of the situation given the margins
and an increased refining output i see a
number of u.s refining companies are
already doing that but others are
already operating at what 90 potentially
going up to 95 percent over the rest of
the summer josh in your mind
are they taking advantage of the
situation
uh absolutely not so uh the the spike
that we saw in refining margins was
directly correlated with the uh
reduction in utilization of chinese and
russian refiners and in particular when
we saw almost a million barrels a day of
russian refined product exports fall off
that's where we saw
these margins go up a lot so so what is
interesting is that us refiners are
actually being good actors and they've
moved up their utilization they're
taking some risks in doing this they're
moved up their utilization from 90 to 95
so i think they're actually doing the
right thing and it does show that
refining capacity is tight but the cause
of it is not
us or european refiners price gouging
it's the opposite they're they're doing
what they can is that there is sort of
limited refining capacity and some of it
particularly in russia and china has
been offline
thomas what would it take to scale up
refining capacity here
well
if you're going to do it in the united
states you're going to have to expand
existing refineries or build new ones
that's a little bit doubtful but you
know there's a whole caribbean region
there's the issue of venezuela and i
know the administration the united
states administration is working on
trying to get the maduro administration
to make some democratic concessions to
legitimize raising you know lifting some
sanctions and getting production going
uh and perhaps doing something with the
refineries i mean there's a huge
potential there and it's i mean it's not
only
coming off of covid and as uh
bob pointed out and josh both all the
problems of adjusting it's also this war
in ukraine so it's a very funny
situation it's a short term that's very
volatile and very uncertain both in
crude and refined products but if you go
out three years or so or more
i would say
i mean this is a geostrategic judgment
the west and their allies in asia japan
taiwan and so forth are going to take
turn
uh russia from a first world sort of i'm
sorry from sort of an energy superpower
in oil and gas to sort of a second-rate
player that's exactly what fadi barol
the head of the iea he said just
yesterday at a meeting going forward
after a few years russia will be reduced
to a minor you know player a second
ranked player
and that means there's going to be huge
possibilities for developing oil new
crude development new new fields but
also new refining capacity russia was
supplying two and a half million barrels
a day of refined diesel to northern
europe that's all going to go away and
they can't just send that to asia that
much oil some of it they can but um
there's going to be a big change but in
the meantime who knows if there's going
to be a recession there probably and
there's other problems so short term
it's a little iffy it's very volatile
but longer term there's going to be
growth in the industry there has to be
well let's then talk a little bit more
about the impact of the ukraine war i
believe bob you need specific russian
products also to actually run
some specific types of refineries and as
you alluded to there you obviously need
specific types of crude to then
efficiently produce certain things
diesel for example now we've mentioned
venezuela the sanctions on iran as well
and given that we've seen some
bottlenecks around opec plus production
do you think that russian sanctions have
really contributed to the crunch that
we're seeing
oh i think i think it really has i mean
i don't disagree with the with those
those uh
cutting off uh russian crude but to
punish putin for attacking ukraine but
it does cause a huge upset you know we
were in back in the 90s
late 80s early 90s in the states a lot
of refineries were built or or modified
to handle heavy crudes because that was
primarily what was being produced in the
us
after the the horizontal unconventional
drilling started back in the mid 2000s
2007 2008
that crude is a light sweet crude that
the gulf coast refineries can't handle
so
under the obama administration
we began being able to export again so
we're actually exporting light sweet uh
light sweet crude and importing heavy
crude that the refineries can handle so
the the solution to that obviously is
that to build new refining capacity or
to modify back to where we can handle
the higher
higher gravity crudes
but that is part of the issue of having
to move we're moving we're exporting and
importing uh refined product and we're
importing and exporting crude
because all oil is not equal it has to
match the facility that's being shipped
to
well then just looking in terms of the
margins of the prices that we're seeing
partly due to the ukraine war refined
oil products have risen what between 30
and nearly 140
since russia invaded ukraine back in in
february now that's compared to less
than a 15 percent increase for a barrel
of crude josh do you think that we
should expect that margin to increase
even further as the war drags on
no no i think i think it's uh it's
already started to compress
so crack spreads i think got
over 60 i think they might have even
gotten over 70 very briefly which was a
70 per barrel margin uh for refineries
and refined products versus the input of
crude um it's already down below 50. um
i think we might be getting to 40 or so
uh recently and so i think i think that
there is this trend which is as russian
um refined product exports are back up
and as chinese teapot refineries ramp
back up as well and as their export
quotas are increased um i expect more
sort of normalization uh compressed
refining margins and potentially higher
oil prices as more oil is consumed in
refining
to then deliver these oil products and
just to explain to our viewers the
teapot refineries you're talking about
in china are the non-state
um refineries that exist there i do want
to talk about china because it's
currently what the world's second
largest refiner but potentially going to
become the largest very soon but from
the figures it really doesn't like to
export its product so last year
according to its own customs agency it
it shipped about 1.21 million barrels a
day of refined fuel so fuel oil gasoline
diesel jet fuel that's what seven
percent of its total refining capacity
and now it's been cutting exports even
further thomas why is it doing that
given the state of of the world economy
well you know if they've got a market
for it at home you know why would you
generally speaking why would you export
uh refined products uh if you have a
market for it at home um i know i think
things are a little bit complicated
right now um
uh it
in china you know everybody thought that
they were recovering and then they went
through this whole series of lockdowns
again so now you have a situation where
um you know everybody expects a
recession so demand is going to soften
so that should ease all this stuff out
okay
that should ease the demand out but at
the same time china's coming off of
these lockdowns and there's going to be
some expansion there so even though
you're kind of going to a recession
you're going to have some expansion in
china and it's a complicated situation
[Music]
i wouldn't expect china to export you
know what
anything that's not surplus
what i wish they would do is uh used
more of their refining capacity so they
could have kept
exporting during this last coveted
shutdown but that isn't what they did
um bob you're sitting in houston how do
you think the u.s is viewing the limit
that china has put on its on its refined
oil exports is biden keen to see that
increase
well i think in in the states
we're the industry in any way
the industry believes this is going to
work through over the next couple of
years for for instance i was looking at
the nymex wti crude curve this morning
you know we're like 94 or 95 dollars a
barrel in the near month
in december of 23 it's 77
so it's almost 20 less in two years out
so the expectation is this is going to
stabilize i think
where we're focused i believe that what
the industry talks about anyway
is
being able to import more fruits that
venezuela is close to being and that's
another two and a half million barrels a
day it won't come up immediately but
it'll help and that helps our refining
capacity stay full with the the heavy
crude that comes from venezuela uh china
i think is using their refinery capacity
like they use everything else in their
economy as a weapon against countries
like the us and the and the the eu and i
think that's some that's got to be
something that we consider well given
the state of play let's look at where we
go from here then given the current
situation so in order for oil refining
margins to drop and for prices to come
down there needs to be more capacity and
for that you obviously need investment
should we be expecting fresh investment
in oil refining given the margins josh
would you be encouraging people to
invest in this
yeah so i think that the challenge for
refining in the us is more related to
environmental regulations and permitting
than it is desire to expand
so exxon has been expanding refineries
here to uh better process uh light sweet
crude coming from um coming from shale
and west texas and uh you know they've
had all kinds of issues and there's just
kind of this tremendous uh sort of
regulatory and tax burden uh one one
thing i do want to address the the the
status of the the forward curve i think
there's a there's a lot of
misconceptions around it and uh it being
in backwardation so oil being a hundred
dollars right now and seventy dollars
two years from now is actually an
indication of a very tight oil market
and it does it incentivizes oil to get
pulled out of storage right now and
historically when it's been in that sort
of circumstance oil prices have actually
gone up over time not down so so when
you look at the incentives there there
is an incentive to invest both in
upstream as well as in refining um and
what we're seeing is that there's a very
tight market there's a lot of
tightness in in the service capacity to
be able to do these expansions but
specifically for findings specifically
in the us there are huge regulations and
taxes that get in the way well given
that we are talking about this green
transition and president biden has
obviously said he wants to focus on
renewables and i see a number of the
refineries that have gone offline are
actually switching further towards
biofuels thomas do you see that trend
continuing or will there be some kind of
a shift given the current state of
affairs
well i think
ever since the
the ethanol revolution which wasn't a
revolution after all there was never
cellulastic ethanol
um i think the idea of biofuels per se
is
you know really not going to take off
what everybody looks at is electric
vehicles now
if you look at i think we need a dose of
reality here and there was a big problem
let's say the last decade but also even
during corona of uh sort of official
optimism or something
you know 94 of everything that moves
here in germany germany's supposed to be
one of the greenest countries around if
you listen to the government but 94 of
everything that moves moves on oil
distillates
and you know it's about the same in the
united states everywhere in the world
you can look at how many electric car uh
plants have been built in the world and
how many they're producing i mean i
haven't looked at it really close in a
year or two but if you look at the rate
of increase that you expect just from
the expansion of population and wealth
in china and india and africa you see
how many more cars how many more
vehicles will be on the road you'll be
lucky if uh electric cars can take up
that those new cars much less the whole
base
of the continuing base of
oil fueled cars that are still out there
so
oil companies were under a lot of
pressure to look like they're doing
everything to transform to some new
world
but the vehicles simply aren't there the
the electric vehicles aren't there
there's major problems with batteries
and those supply chains and somehow this
has to be balanced that people can work
on that without scaring
scaring the wits out of you know the
companies and shaming the companies into
not investing
and that's what happened the last few
years by not investing i mean there was
also corona but by not investing now
we're stuck and you'll see opec has been
raising their quota biden asked them to
raise their quota well certain sense it
doesn't do any good they can't meet
their quota they're a couple million
barrels behind and what they're supposed
to have produced over the last several
months so a lot of investments are
needed and a stable situation a more
realistic pragmatic policy here
well in terms of pragmatic policy we're
talking also about very specific kinds
of distillates and demand for those
right so bob let me ask you about the
trade-off that exists for refiners by my
understanding
let's say there's a shortage of diesel
like we're seeing now you rejig things
to produce more diesel that means you
end up producing potentially less jet
fuel and then air travels also
rebounding post pandemic so trying to
then produce both reduces the output of
petrol what should be the focus here in
your mind
well i i think what you said is is
correct also
the the challenge that we have in states
is getting different fuels to different
parts of the country
for instance we we import gasoline into
california because it because it's it's
easier to import it in rather than
shipping it from the gulf coast because
of the transportation issues and so
there's all these different different
issues that we have to set to to deal
with in terms of getting the right fuel
in the right place and i agree with
thomas on the whole electric vehicle
issue
i don't think we can replace uh the the
petrol powered vehicles with uh
electric vehicles fast enough especially
with manufacturing battery issues the
recycling of those batteries and and we
haven't talked about the power grid the
power grid is another gigantic challenge
especially right now in texas and so
with all those different things floating
around
the most important thing is to keep
commerce moving which is primarily jet
fuel diesel and gasoline
well if oil refineries in the us aren't
necessarily coming back online we're not
necessarily seeing the investment that's
required to do that i see more
refineries are though being built in the
middle east and asia josh very briefly
how soon do you think that could make a
difference
yes so there are there are projects uh
ongoing um i think the bigger thing is
just the ramp up in the independent
refineries in china the teapots as well
as uh ramp up in russian refined product
exports and so between the two of those
um it does look like refining the
refining market is coming into balance
in the short term
i'm not sure there's going to be a
balance over the next few years i think
there's probably insufficient refining
capacity right now that's reliable
relative to the likely demand increase i
agree with the other panelists i i don't
see the electric uh vehicle transition
uh coming on fast enough to be able to
address this shortage of oil and refined
capacity so i think it makes sense to be
considering expanding additional
refining capacity even though this
short-term sort of super squeeze and
refining margins is starting to
dissipate clearly something that isn't
going to be resolved anytime soon well
thank you to all of our guests bob
kavanagh thomas o'donnell and josh young
and thank you to for watching you can
see this program again anytime by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle is at aj inside
story from me nastasiate and the whole
team here in doha bye for now
you